Три роки тому вони влаштовували акції
за звільнення Надії Савченко з російського ув'язення:
міністри закордонних справ ЄС тримали в руках її портрети,
депутати Європарламенту вдягали футболки з її фото.
Тепер же, після обвинувачень у тероризмі
і спробі державного перевороту, активні захисники Савченко
намагаються зрозуміти, що сталося.
Надія Савченко - одна з тих українців, які
зіштовхнулися з надзвичайно суворими викликами у своєму житті
і отримали дуже екстремальний досвід.
Спершу вона стала героїнею, потім - членом парламенту,
а згодом Надія зіштовхнулася з усіма проблемами,
пов'язаними з тим, що вона не відповідала
очікуванням мейнстриму щодо неї.
У часи ув'язнення Надії Савченко в Росії
Ельмар Брок очолював комітет з міжнародних справ Європаралменту.
Завдяки його зусиллям було ухвалено не одну резолюцію за звільнення Савченко,
а Європарламент не припиняв тиснути на Росію,
поки полонена льотчиця не вийшла на свободу.
Я завжди підтримував її, коли вона була в ув'язенні в Росії.
Але згодом, як виявилося, вона не обрала конструктивну роль
у побудові майбутньої України. І в цьому вся проблема.
Якщо поглянути на те, що Савченко заявляла публічно та на відео,
то вона хотіла позбутися Порошенка за допомогою військової сили,
що в будь-якій країні незаконно.
Надія Савченко знову в залі суду, але вже не в російському.
І знову на ній одяг із тризубом, і вона знову
оголошує голодування. Чи може її історія зашкодити звільненню
решти українських політв'язнів з-за російських ґрат?
Ні, це індивідувуальний випадок. І її поведінка
не повинна стати перепоною для підтримки інших людей,
яких утримує Росія. Це було б несправедливо.
Без сумніву, було абсолютно правильно боротися за звільнення Савченко.
І я продовжу боротися за свободу всіх
політичних в'язнів з України, особливо тих,
хто став жертвами російського судочинства в Криму.
Для так званих друзів України в Брюсселі
останні події стали, безумовно, неприємною новиною.
Проте, за словами Ельмара Брока,
українські інституції відреагували відповідно.
Цілком правильно, що українська держава
відреагувала саме так. І що Київ буде проводити розслідування,
щоб з'ясувати, які саме були плани Савченко,
які мотиви, хто допомагав. Цей випадок показав,
що держава спроможна реагувати на подібні виклики.
Поки Брюссель стежить за розвитком подій в Україні.
А також за тим, як саме буде відбуватися судовий процес:
чи буде він прозорим, неупередженим та
чи відповідатиме принципу верховенства права.